Hi, this is Bizhan Tong and I’m the writer,
producer and self-funder of THE ESCORT, a
feature chronicling gender perception within
society by way of the industry.
Now today I’m here to talk to you about
5 problems I faced when making THE ESCORT,
the trials and tribulations we encountered,
what it would mean for production and how
we overcame them.
But before I do so let’s take a brief moment
to recap the journey and explain how we got
to this point.
Now for those of you watching I’ an avid
fan of film, molded by it, living it, breathing
it, dependent on it.
And after writing my first feature screenplay
at the age of 12 I knew that was what I wanted
to do with my life.
I’ve spent almost everyday since writing
or tinkering with scripts.
I made my first proper short in 2008 for the
short film called TICKET about toxic masculinity
and earned my first producing credit that
same year with FIX, a feature starring Olivia
Wilde.
Then after I continued to rise as later projects
and honed my craft to the course at Raindance
and volunteered to shoot corporate videos
for free in order to try out different styles
with someone I know production designer Charles
McCarry on TV series I was developing.
I finally I formed a production company Phoenix
Waters Productions in 2015 in order to bring
my stories to life tell of different genres
amassed over a decade of all high-concepts
dealing with personal and social themes and
the first feature I wanted to make was THE
ESCORT.
Now I had no funding in place but I knew this
story was special and the right feature debut.
So I set money aside from my day job to fund
the film.
I spent several months interviewing current
and former workers to lend credence to the
script.
It was important to me that their views be
echoed in the particular character’s words
rather than my assumptions, wrote the screenplay
with budget constraints in mind, two characters,
one location and spoke with an accomplished
female director about helming the project
but exploring the escort industry wasn’t
of interest to her.
And so I made the decision that this would
be my feature directorial debut as well.
Cut to almost three years later and The Escort
is about the premiere in New York at the Kew
Gardens Festival of Cinema.
Reaction from those who’ve seen it has been
immensely positive.
Distributor are already making offers.
The company now has exceptional board of directors
and I’m busy prepping my next feature NIGHT
RIDE.
The first few years weren’t easy and so
without further ado here are five problems
I faced when filming THE ESCORT.
1.
Timing
A nine day shoot.
Actor Kevin Lesley plays the client Eric in
the movie and does a phenomenal job as well.
Kevin had other film commitments at the time
which meant we only had 9 days to shoot a
feature because on day 10 he would have to
shave his head for a role.
And knowing THE ESCORT takes place in real
time there would have been glaring continuity
errors and I didn’t want to slap him with
a Fantastic Four wig.
Plus I didn’t have the budget for one.
Now we had one month between casting Olivia
Moore as the title character and shooting
the film as it was still finalizing the crew
and searching for the right location to keep
production cost low.
So I went to the studio room in canary wolf
where the actors and I would work on refining
the characters, their world and the execution
of their dialogue.
I had a very specific approach in mind.
The actors continued to rehearse themselves
in even the studio or on Skype and I went
for the script listing every shot I wanted.
Please note I could only afford one camera.
So for a lot of retakes it was important not
to keep the action static.
That way I could keep production efficient
and ensure them we were moving at pace.
Doing the shoot the camera op, DP and I would
hold a meeting every morning on the train
to discuss the shots we needed while in the
evening the actors would rehearse while I
would sleep at 2:00 a.m. the next night and
wake up at 3:30 for the following day’s
shoot.
And kudos to the cast.
There was one scene in the kitchen where it
was important to accomplish it in one take
which was a challenge for all in the technicolor
climate but especially for them as was a lot
of dialogue as they couldn’t afford to flub
a line.
Everyone was passionate, everyone was involved
and on the last day we shot for 17 hours straight
in order to complete the film culminating
in shoot the bedroom scene which was the trickiest
and more emotional one to do.
Fortunately morale was in tact which is the
key to success in any production.
2.
Noisy Neighbors!
A war zone next store.
If I could make any change to THE ESCORT is
would be shoot at another location not because
of the location itself which I am grateful
to have been offered but because of the property
next door which sounded like a Michael Bay
blockbuster.
Prior to the shoot I had been advised that
building works would be completed prior to
when principal photography began.
Alas when we arrived on set we found this
wasn’t the case and had to battle our way
through the sound of power drills, saws and
heavy machinery for the duration of the shoot.
While the builders were claiming we were shooting
a film, I never even told them the title.
Ultimately there was a lot of negotiating
involved.
Ultimately there was a lot of negotiation
involved and I would frequently visit the
house to arrange to arrange time slot of silence
or ask for a specific amount of time to get
a take right.
But we also used that time to stay productive.
When it was noisy we would shoot B-roll footage
or take lunch so we could shoot when they
were on break.
And during an off-screen monologue when the
camera needed to focus on the listener’s
reaction we decided to shoot the scene and
weave in the monologue in post.
Now not everything was sorted this way.
The bathroom scene which was shot perfectly
had to sound butchered.
But thanks to ADR work by Phil Clemens and
a positive relationship with the builders
next door we were able to get through it and
the final tract is a testament to this and
it doesn’t look or sound like we faced these
problems.
3.
A change of DP
While the director has a vision.
The director of photography is operative to
the execution of that vision.
And so the look, start and feel of the film
had been discussed well in advance as a DP
perceives it from a technical standpoint.
Their style (much like the directors) permeating
each production.
When the original DP needed to leave early
for personal reasons, this threatened to derail
the plan we had in place.
I was conscious that this would distract the
cast and crew as I needed them focused and
giving their all, particularly the actors
who had some challenging scenes to perform.
So we agreed to keep this news from them after
the replacement was found with the DP continuing
until the end of the week.
During each break from filming I would leave
the house in an effort to find someone on
such short notice and fortunately the DP introduced
me to someone (Beau Richard James) a steadicam
operator who agreed to step into the DP role
in order to keep production on track.
The other problem was style as their visual
angles would be different than each other.
Fortunately my intent had always been that
every scene would be shot in a subtly different
way to effect the story and those characters
in that moment.
So how can that style be different from what
I was trying to do in the context of what
I was trying to do as long as it wasn’t
radically and Beau worked tirelessly along
with other camera operators often putting
in extra days to get the look and shot.
We had this transitional period as we moved
from one DP to the next and because of his
production stayed on track and we crafted
some of the finest moments in the film from
the dance scene to the bedroom with our new
addition to the team.
4.
The British Weather
Freakish wind and rain during a supposed sunny
out door shoot.
THE ESCORT takes place in real time and it
was important that it set during the day since
nighttime shady activities tend to be synonamous
with each other.
And I wanted to underline the activities that
go on in quiet, pleasant neighborhoods on
seemingly bright days.
We had set one morning to set all the outdoor
scenes based on the schedule we had in place
and the weather forecast.
But unfortunately one of the freakiest moments
on the shoot, that morning was met with high
winds and light rain.
That mean Kevin’s clothes were flapping
about in the wind and they had to almost shout
their lines to be heard.
The equipment had all been moved outside of
the shoot so prepping a different scene and
moving inside would have taken at least an
hour.
And I knew based on the schedule shooting
in on a different day would have sacrificed
time on more technical and more technical
and emotionally challenging scenes.
This is why I pose a question to you, what
would you do?
In our case Beau waited until mini hurricane
outside until there was a brief moment when
the winds and rain subsided and we were able
to shoot the scene.
But we were extraordinarily fortunate to get
it.
So I’d been keen to hear your thoughts.
5.
No Backing Up The Backups
Loosing the Climax of Act One
If there is one piece of advice that I would
give anyone is to have a good day director.
It was the biggest shock during production
that we lost the climax of Act 1.
Not just the original but the back up leading
to subsequently forming multiple backups for
the rest of production.
One take remained in tact but it only showed
on of the actors and we knew we had no choice
but to reshoot say for a brief flirtation
of having it done anime style but it was something
we avoided.
We prepped to shoot five months later when
Kevin had grown his hair but we no longer
had access to location and had to shoot at
Liverpool Street.
Now this poses it’s own challenges because
it’s clear we’re shooting at a different
location.
And considering that we have the escort’s
apartment, this would be a problem.
Now we looked at various options, maybe we’d
have a blow-out in the background and shoot
it there.
But what we ultimately decided to do was to
have the props on the set and most importantly
the sofa since that is where the climax moment
takes place, bring that over to the set and
film in a very tight manner that would focus
on the characters’ faces.
This actually worked ideally for us because
looking at the scene and what was occurring
there was an argument and we were looking
to break them apart.
So from a visual standpoint we thought why
not just have them not share the scene?
So two days before we were about to shoot
the film, I had a personal issue and my Mom
was diagnosed with Cancer but this was important
that we keep it quiet from the cast and crew
again because I need them to focus and give
it their all.
It was an emotional scene.
It was an important scene to do.
And so I worked with them, I kept these personal
things private and we were able to shoot the
scene.
We worked afterwards through editing, it enabled
us to utilize the scene that we had (that
one take) that we had in the location with
what we created afterwards.
Fortunately it meshed well and it worked well
and I’m really proud and happy with what
we’ve created.
So those are the 5 problems I faced making
THE ESCORT and I hope you never have to face
those during your production and ultimately
thank you very much for your time.
I hope this was an educational one.
And I wish you the best of luck with your
films.
Thanks!